[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à cette époque je ne savais pas ce qu'il
pouvait nous faire ni à quel point cette
guerre
allez me changer
et elle s'équipe nos forces spéciales
c'est aussi une révolution féministe non
notre révolution ne connaît aucune
frontière
durant des milliers d'années les hommes
munger son passé sur le corps des femmes
[Applaudissements]
ici pour la première fois nous ne
craigne ptv smartour du parlement y a
pas d'eau mais si j'ai décidé de
rejoindre mes soeurs d'armes pour venger
mon père est sauvé mon frère
[Musique]
c'est quoi ton nom zalla moi cela est
celle qui conduit si american snipers sa
chef on appelle la lionne de kovalev
bien joué
[Applaudissements]
arrivé
une fois qu'on a plus besoin d'elle les
femmes sont est passé de l'histoire
effacée de la société
et renvoyer j'ai fait
pour être des acteurs
mais pas cette fois